nation's largest cattle industry lobby
group is fighting to defend the
traditional meaning of the word meat
u.s. Cattlemen's Association filed a
petition last month with the Department
of Agriculture it argues lab-grown and
plant-based products should not use the
terms meat or beef on their labels Jamie
yuccas visited a California ranch to
find out what's at stake on this
sprawling Northern California ranch
Kellie Fogarty's family has raised Black
Angus cattle for five generations we
spend a lot of time out here with them
Fogerty also represents hundreds of
ranchers as the executive vice president
of the US Cattlemen's Association for
them defining meat is easy when
consumers think of meat you want them to
think of these guys yes we want them to
think of this we don't want them to
think of a laboratory we don't want them
to think of something that's created
under a microscope the Association is
concerned about the increase of animal
free products that have names like this
one beefy beyond beef crumbles a
plant-based product the company says
tastes like real beef the Cattlemen's
federal petition argues the labels beef
or meat should inform consumers that the
product is derived naturally from
animals as opposed to alternative
proteins such as plants or artificially
grown in a laboratory there's an
opportunity but Ethan Brown the CEO of
beyond meat says it's time to rethink
that definition the reason we want to
use the word meat is that we firmly
believe that this is a piece of meat
that if you look at me not in terms of
origin but if you look at meat in terms
of composition we are hitting all those
key points competition at beyond meats
Los angeles-area lab Brown's team is
working to replicate the texture color
and sensory experience of eating a
traditional hamburger I think it's a
mistake to dictate to the consumer what
language they can use this isn't the
first fight over food labeling dairy
farmers have so far been unsuccessful in
their battle to make the word milk
exclusive to products from cows in some
stores these animal free alternatives
are currently sold alongside their
competitors and we just don't want there
to be any confusion when it
to our product do you think it's
confusing to the consumer no I think the
tumor smart I think in Sumer knows what
plant-based meat is meat alternative
sales were up 6% last year and are
valued at around 500 million dollars
that's still crumbs compared to the real
meat industry that makes more than 50
billion annually but the USDA says it's
considering the cattle ranchers petition
and could finally decide which foods
meet the definition I want this ranch to
be here for generations to come after me
the consumer is moving interestingly
they say look if I can continue to eat
meat but it's a plant-based I mean I
know get all these benefits health
environment and welfare et cetera why
wouldn't I do that for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas near Oakdale California I
think both sides raised some interesting
points but as we were saying a good old
burger with some cheese it's hard to
beat
it's hard to beat for me anyway I'll
just speak for myself is